and don't let don't let the word
possible do what it does in our English
language what's that well it's how you
say Well With God all things are
possible that leaves it sort of like a
vague Open Door yeah he could do it if
he wanted to right the word doesn't mean
that in the Greek when it says With God
all things are possible it means god is
full of divine power to do it and make
it happen that's right do you feel like
you're in an impossible situation does
God's word have anything to give us hope
find out on this episode of LED live
foreign
[Music]
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at LED live I got my special
friend Eric Wilson on the show it's good
to be here man always a pleasure having
you on this guy is a wealth of knowledge
and I want to talk about the power of
prayer because I think Amen in this time
man we've been like Christianity it just
seems like it's gotten to a lukewarm
like you know having the form of
godliness but denying the power thereof
right and I know that this year has been
a tough year for me I've had a lot of
hardships come against me and you were
really uh you were really a big help
when I called you and you told me Mikey
there's bible promises that can help you
in this situation because you were in a
very tough situation as well and so I
learned a lot from you and um so I want
to share with people I know a lot of
people are going through some tough
times right now it's been a lot of death
a lot of sickness a lot of marriage has
fallen apart a lot of kids going
prodigal you know and parents are
feeling hopeless spouses are feeling
hopeless a lot of hopelessness in the
world and so you know what amazes me is
like what you just said about
um about God's promises
a lot of times it seems like now at the
end of the world right before Christ is
returning Christians act like prayer is
just a formality yes you know when I say
prayer when we bow down at church or I
say or say prayer before the meal but we
don't realize we're actually talking
to the Living God Amen the life-giving
God and and when you realize who God is
prayer becomes a living thing you're not
you're not just saying words but so many
Christians that's how they feel they're
just mumbling words and they're like
what's the point I mean I don't ever see
answers right imagine if you had a
situation where
maybe you needed help financially or
something and you could go talk to a
King
we can talk to the King of Kings amen
creator of the whole world Amen then he
has a cattle in a thousand hills there's
nothing that he can't answer or do and
so often we we think real small when it
comes to prayer like Lord help me find
those car keys Lord help me get a good
grade He does care about those little
things but he wants to pray he wants us
to pray big prayers he wants to answer
things that seem impossible because only
he can answer them amen and I've seen
that so many times where God comes
through at the last second we feel like
God are you ever going to do anything
and then suddenly at the last minute it
happens and you realize that had been
God there's no other way and he I think
he does it that way on purpose just to
show us no it wasn't your efforts it
wasn't coincidence that's right yeah
amen so I want to start off with
something very important God is not a
liar he's not a liar we got some verses
so Hebrews 6 18 says that that by two
immutable things in which it was
impossible for God to lie we might have
a strong con consolation who have fled
for Refuge to lay hold upon the hopes
that before us can I interject something
yeah
go back one one slide God is not a liar
how many lies do you have to tell to be
a liar just one one yeah
wow that means God
cannot lie
that means everything in his word is yea
and amen he's the way the truth and the
life he is the embodiment of Truth with
the embodiment of Love Like It's amazing
amen think about God man he is the truth
that's like a foundation if I think that
God is like wishy-washy or maybe or
kinda or sorta well no wonder people
don't expect answers because they don't
think God they don't understand his
nature wow it's impossible for him to
lie yeah it's like if you if you call a
friend and and the first two times they
really help you but then the next two or
three times they don't when you come
into trouble you're probably not going
to call that friend because man I can't
really depend on them right but he's
never told a lie not even once so why
don't we depend on them it's neat too
because it says it's impossible for him
to lie if he speaks something it is
that's right it's like you know we're
standing outside on a beautiful sunshine
day and it's 90 degrees you know and God
looks up and goes look at the snow
coming down the moment he says it it
starts snowing that's right it it's not
that he won't lie he can't because if he
speaks it it happens it happens amen
Titus 1 2 you want to read that one
this one's good it says in Hope of
eternal life which God that cannot lie
promised us before the world began uh
even before the world began God promised
each of us
eternal life
I remember years ago when the Lord first
Set Me Free an older man of God told me
that on the phone one day he said Eric
he said when you're reading the promises
they're written to you personally read
your name into them amen God promised
you and I eternal life before the world
began he promised that and he can't lie
amen oh this is good all right Psalm 33
6-9 says but the word of the Lord where
the heavens made
he just spoke it he the words made it
happen and oh man we have a powerful God
and all the hosts of them by the breath
of his mouth for he spake and it was
done he commanded and it stood fast like
you know something that I love about
that go back just one slide
six thousand years God said something he
said let the Earth bring forth green
grass
it's still doing it yeah
he commanded and it still stands fast
yeah by the word of the Lord where the
heavens made it says he upholds
everything he holds everything up in
their place by his word and the word is
Jesus wow dude this is getting good
because we're showing you that God is
powerful all-powerful that he doesn't
lie so why can't we come to him with
prayer amen oh man you want to read
Isaiah 55 9-11 this one was a great help
for my wife and I let's listen to this
promise
for as the heavens are higher than the
earth so are my ways higher than your
ways and so are my thoughts higher than
your thoughts
with my thoughts I'm like there's no way
that I would be forgiving and God's like
yeah but that's your thoughts my
thoughts are higher than yours of course
I'm going to forgive yeah
um yeah
for as the rain cometh down and the snow
from heaven and returns not feather it
means it doesn't go back the way it came
down amen but it Waters the Earth and it
makes it bring forth and Bud blossoms
so that it may give seed to the sower
and bread to the eater
so shall my word be that goeth forth out
of my mouth it shall not return unto me
void but it he shall accomplish that
which I please and he shall prosper in
all whereto I sent him amen and remember
Jesus is the word that was made flesh so
when I think about the word of God it's
not just you know words written on a
page it's the son of almighty God it's
his word because that's how he speaks to
us I I love like there's a meme that
says uh God will you just talk to me and
it's like there it is amen how many
people are not looking in the Bible and
they're just like just tell them just
talk to me well I encourage all of our
listeners and everybody that's watching
right now try it for one week that's
what that older man of God told me he
said try it for seven days every time
you open your Bible read it out loud so
that you're not just speaking it but
you're hearing it and you're seeing it
and read your name into every promise
and I did that and it was it was like
life in a week it was it was
life-changing I like how it says his
ways are higher than his thoughts are
higher than ours and it was just our
thoughts are so limited we're looking at
a situation there's like this is
impossible there's no way my spouse is
going to come back there's no way my
child is going to become a Believer
there's no way I can get the money to
pay this bill that's due tomorrow yeah
his thoughts are way higher than ours
he's like really no way let me show you
amen so numbers 23 19 says God is not a
man that he should lie nor a son of a
man that he should repent as he said and
will not do or has he spoken and will
not make it good like look if God said
it it's going to happen his word doesn't
return unto him void like we just read
over and over and over Old Testament the
New Testament it says repeatedly if he
says it it's true he cannot lie
do you know I'm just going to interject
something
um
I've had a lot of people that have
contacted you know my wife and I at our
ministry and they're like yeah but I
prayed for this and I haven't seen the
answer if you go through the gospels
throughout all four gospels there's a
clue
Jesus says according to your faith be it
unto you
so he that asks but doesn't believe
James chapter 1 and 2 says let not that
man think he's going to receive anything
from the Lord and that was a struggle
for me because I was like
God I want to believe but I just
couldn't feel like I could work up Faith
yeah and then all of a sudden I was like
Lord help me and he sent me to Romans 10
17 and it says faith will come by
hearing and hearing by the word of God
so if you're struggling to believe God's
promises
read them out loud and if you read them
out loud with your name into it within
just a short period of time the faith
will come yeah the reason why Jesus said
in John 6 63 he said the words that I
speak unto you they are spirit that
doesn't mean they're just spiritual yeah
it means they are Spirit
in their life and their life so when
you're reading it the first time you
read it you may go I didn't do anything
the second time you read it the third
all of a sudden something inside of you
changes yeah that's that is Spirit
that's God's spirit and I've uh just to
kind of identify with maybe somebody
who's in a very
hopeless State you know I have I
continue to be sometimes in and out it's
like waves you know but there's times
where I just feel spiritually drained
I'm like I can't I just can't pray I
just can't read
go to YouTube and type in the Bible make
the Bible read to you and and I'll do
that I'll I'll listen to a sermon
somebody that I know has a message on
some I'm dealing with or I'll uh just
have the Bible play and then it's like
the spiritual Vigor comes up in me I'm
like that's right yes amen amen by
hearing I'm hearing you know awesome so
Ezekiel 36 36 says you want to read that
one yeah this one I love this is God
talking about his word he says when I do
this and if you get a chance read the
whole chapter Ezekiel 36 especially
verse 22 till the end
he says when I do these things that I'm
promising you then the Heathen that are
left round about you shall know that I
the Lord build the ruined places that
means your life your home your job your
health I build what's ruined
I the Lord build the ruined places and I
plant that which was desolate for I the
Lord have spoken it and I will do it
amen he speaks it it comes to pass and
you notice
all this brings glory to him amen
answered prayer brings glory to him and
if his reputation is on the line he's
not going to let his reputation be
ruined so if we put our faith in him and
say God you said it it's your promise
we will never be ashamed if we put our
trust in him we can't be ashamed because
we serve The God Who Cannot Lie and and
just a thought
it's not like God is like an egotistical
maniac and he just wants glory yeah
he's like a father that loves showing
how much he loves his children amen he
loves to do good things for those that
believe in him yeah I don't think it's
egotistical to say how much you love
your children or how much you love your
wife you know amen I want to prove to
you I love them more than anyone amen
that's a great thing
so all that God is not a liar everything
he says comes to pass we have a powerful
God but we're in a spiritual war so
we're going to look at
why we're faced with trials and
tribulations and prodigal spouses and
prodigal children and all these things
because we're in a spiritual war there's
an enemy out there who's attacking us
especially Christians when you got one
foot in the world one foot in the church
Satan tends to kind of step back and
just watch you and he's laughing because
you're right where he wants he you are
right where he wants you yeah but when
you surrender I tell people this when
you surrender to God get ready for
battle man get ready for spiritual
warfare because you have a Target on
your head he is angry with the remnant
who keeps the commands of God when you
dedicate your life to him he's coming
after you and so II Corinthians 4 4 says
in whom the God of this world has
blinded the minds of them which believe
not so if you're in a situation
say with your spouse
this is not a battle between you and him
or her this is not a battle between your
flesh this is a spiritual war the enemy
has blinded their minds it's hard for us
sometimes because God has opened our
eyes to certain things like there was a
time when I was a self-professed
Christian that I thought people were
kind of extremists that thought Harry
Potter was pushing witchcraft I was like
it's a kids show like it's a kids movie
like let the people imagine
but then when the Blinder fell off I was
like whoa like I see it for what it is
now yeah I was literally blinded by the
enemy and so that's where a lot of
people are like the things we talk about
on the show if people are like you guys
are crazy and we're looking at it like
it's plain as day and you're thinking
we're crazy just for pointing it out
it's because the God of this world Satan
has been has been blinding people and we
need God to knock the blinders off like
Saul on the road to Damascus he was a
Christian persecutor but the blinders
got knocked off his eyes like scales and
all of a sudden he became the New
Testament author of The Bible you know
and became one of the most well-known
authors of the Bible amen
Ephesians 6 12 says for we do not
wrestle against flesh and blood this
isn't a battle between us and anybody
else but against principalities against
Powers against the rulers of the
darkness of this world against spiritual
hosts of wickedness in Heavenly places
do you know that that's interesting
because
there's a verse and I think it's First
Corinthians chapter 10. it says the
weapons of our Warfare are not carnal so
I mean like when my wife and I went
through the the attack from the enemy
back 15 years ago or actually more than
that now
um
we thought we were fighting each other
but we didn't realize the devil was
whispering to her in her ear the devil's
whispering to me in my ear and we didn't
hear the devil because usually when the
devil talks to you or when evil spirits
are attacking you they whisper in your
voice so you'll think the thoughts are
your own and then you don't pray against
them yeah you're like no that's how I
really feel yeah so you know here I
didn't realize the weapons of our
Warfare are not carnal but they are
Mighty through God they're they're
divine
and it says to pulling down strongholds
and casting down imaginations one of the
two most important weapons that we have
is The Shield of faith and the sword of
the spirit which is the word of God Amen
so the Devil's Angels are messengers
they attack us through words they
whisper lies and doubts and well God
can't do that or you've you've gone too
far God won't forgive you and they keep
Whispering those doubts
but then God's word says something
completely different so when the devil's
Whispering those doubts we've got to
pull out the Sword and the shield of
faith and we've got to read it out loud
and say yeah but God's word says
different amen whatever you got that's
that's false I live in the reality this
is what God's word says amen that's
perfect segue to Isaiah 54 17 that says
that no weapon no weapon not spiritual
carnal whatever no weapon formed against
you shall prosper every tongue which
Rises against you in judgment shout you
shall condemn this is the heritage of
the Servants of the Lord and their
righteousness is of me says the Lord
amen we have a stronger weapon the word
of God what did
Jesus fight with that kindergarten
interject something real quick Mikey
there's a there's a promise in Isaiah 49
verse 24 and 25 and a lot of people will
say yeah but you know how do I how do I
pray for this person because they're in
bondage but they got themselves there
they sold themselves to the enemy right
you know Jesus actually says in the Old
Testament he says you've sold yourself
for naught that you have been redeemed
without money wow and then he says here
in Isaiah 49 verse 24 and 25 it says
shall the prey be taken from the mighty
or shall the lawful captive be delivered
they sold themself they are lawfully
Satan's prey he says but thus saith the
Lord Yahweh Jehovah even the captives of
the mighty shall be taken away and the
prey of the terrible shall be delivered
for I will contend with him that is
contending with thee and I will save thy
children amen well that's that's hope
for people that think they might have
sold their soul to Satan or whatever
like it's never irredeemable no you can
do that and you he can offer you all the
kingdoms of the world but it doesn't
mean that Jesus can't take it back amen
so you want to read Acts 26 18. yeah
this this is a verse that an older lady
of God a good friend of my wife and I
had shown me because we were really
praying for our son and our daughter
because we'd raised them to know Jesus
but you know you get to a certain age
where you've got to make that it's got
to be personal you've got to know him
for yourself and this was one of the
promises that she shared with us it says
and the apostle was was writing here as
if it was a prayer he said Lord You know
open their eyes turn them from Darkness
to light and from the power of Satan
unto God so that they may receive
forgiveness of sins and inheritance
among them which are Sanctified by faith
that is in me wow so this is actually
something you can pray for somebody that
even somebody you don't know sometimes
I'll see people on a Hollywood preview
for a movie or a a an actress or an
actor or a musician in your life like
yeah they're doing wrong we need to war
warn the world about the wrong they're
doing
that I need to start praying for that
person yeah you know what about Marilyn
Manson can you imagine what if he came
to Christ like genuinely gave his life
to Jesus and renounced all the
wickedness he's that would turn the
world upside down it would why don't we
all start praying for him no because
that that opens a door for God to be
able to do something that he he has a
hard time doing otherwise so notice it
says which are Sanctified by faith that
is in me is that saying my faith is
going to help their eyes to be open and
them to be turned to from Darkness to
light well right there it says we're
asking that God will do this open their
eyes turn them from the power of Satan
to God so that they can receive
forgiveness
and inheritance among those that are
Sanctified that are made Holy by faith
that is in me Jesus okay God's word he
sanctifies us through his word what's
the word sanctify mean
to make holy Amen to make holy do you
know that in the Bible God said
be holy for I am Holy right I used to
read that and I was like well he's
telling me to do something I'm trying to
be holy and it's not working yeah he
didn't tell the light to try to be light
he said let there be light wow and there
was he said be holy he wants you to
believe it wow he he wants you to
believe it not try to do it
because if you believe it that would be
like my dad coming to me and say
um Mr Wilson Eric I want you
to be my son and I'm like okay I better
try how do I need to do that I've gotta
I was born his son yeah
if he says I am and I believe him then I
live as his son amen if you're a son and
daughter of God it's not trying to be
holy You Are Holy because he said you
are that's right live that way that's
right wow that's good throw off that
trash I mean like you know I remember I
used to drink you know probably like you
I used to drink a couple hundred dollars
worth of alcohol a week by myself yeah I
haven't had a drop in in since I was 20
21 years old well I've never even looked
back and it was like well that was I
mean there was no fight with that yeah
and God's like well Eric what else are
you battling with that you just haven't
taken a promise and said that's mine wow
that's powerful Mark 9 29 says so he
said unto them this kind and now I put
in quote in parentheses of demon because
this is
um the apostles are trying to cast out a
demon and it wasn't working then they
came to Jesus why can't we cast out the
demon and Jesus said this kind can come
out by nothing but by prayer and fasting
now I notice that this is the King James
there's actually some most of the other
translations don't say and fasting and I
think maybe that's like a subtle attack
from the enemy because there's something
powerful about fasting and of course the
apostles were praying so I would just
say this one comes out only by praying
of course they're going to be like we
were praying but he said and fasting so
I think there's something powerful and
fasting I'm still learning about fasting
myself I've
I've done fasting where I don't eat for
a day or maybe I just eat only raw
fruits and vegetables for a certain
extent of time and I've seen it work
I've seen in the past where I I went 30
days with eating just raw fruit and
vegetables and I I wasn't even doing it
for that reason I was actually doing it
for health purposes
and I remember just seeing God move in
big ways I was telling a friend near the
end of that fast I was telling him I was
like man God did this and God did that
and they did this and that lady said oh
because of the fast and it was like a
light bulb went off I was like I didn't
even put that together because I wasn't
fasting for that reason I was fasting
for health but at the same time I was
still getting close to God I was still
praying having Bible study and there is
something to fasting and I don't know
maybe you have more insight on that can
I add something to that um
it's funny because that story where
where Jesus was up on the Mount of
transfiguration and he had taken Peter
James and John with him and the other
nine disciples were down at the foot of
the mountain and this man had brought
his son who was demonically possessed
not a little boy I mean he was probably
bigger
but he had brought him and he asked the
disciples would you cast this demon out
well the disciples had just gotten back
from a missionary trip where they had
cast all kinds of demons out yeah and
they tried to cast this deal it was a
doubt they knew they could do it or they
knew they could do it through Christ
this demon mocked them
while they were trying to cast it out
and then that that really worried them
because they were like what happened
when Jesus came back down after Jesus
had cast a demon out and Jesus was alone
with the disciples before he told them
this the very thing he told them was
they asked him they said why could we
not cast it out he said because of
unbelief oh unbelief unbelief he
actually says that in the gospels so
what I found was is that
it's like what you just described all
these unbelievable things were happening
that you saw while you were fasting
oftentimes those Miracles are happening
all around us but when our belly's full
we don't see them that's true so it's
like when you're fasting your mind
usually after like the third day your
mind becomes like Crystal Clear it's
like you just like it's hard to describe
not saying you you can't do it forever
yeah but your mind becomes crystal clear
and it's like especially if you're
instead of eating the food I'm eating
this I'm I'm spending every time there's
no point in fasting if you're not in the
word right and I've caught myself doing
that I'll try to Fast and the hours in
I'm like I haven't done anything the
word I might as well eat you know it's
like it's pointless well that was what
hit me was is that when you're here and
and your mind becomes clearer like that
it's also helping us to be able to to be
aware of the spiritual world that's
around us so yeah there's there's a lot
of benefit to doing that and like you
said it doesn't have to be just water
yeah it can be just juicing it can be
just apples it can be just fruit it can
be just fruit fruits and vegetables you
know you can say hey I'm gonna instead
of doing three meals a day I'm gonna do
one meal a day right but just doing that
and saying I'm doing this for God not
for for just a selfish reason amen I
like it so when Jesus was being tempted
by Satan in the wilderness what did he
do he didn't try to outsmart them or
argue with them or physically battle
with them what'd he say every time it is
written it is written it is written it
is written what is written the word he
was quoting the word back to Satan he
had to know the word for one you can't
quote the word unless you know it so you
got to be in it you can't just carry the
Bible around like a good luck charm you
have to be in it you have to put those
in your mind and then you have to speak
them
speak them like a like a weapon do you
know it's interesting because
I was never good at memorizing verses
and I used to try I just I wasn't good
at it that wasn't my gift and I heard
all these other people oh I've memorized
a whole chapter in the Bible or I've
memorized and that's great I'm not
against that
but when that older man of God told me
to start reading the Bible out loud and
reading my name into the promises I
found that after a year of doing that
every time I was reading it out loud God
was writing it in the heart and I can't
go and just pull it but it's like the
moment you need it it's there and it's
like you don't even have to think about
it because it has been written in your
heart and there's a verse that talks
about that don't worry about what you'll
say when you're taken before Kings and
all this stuff that the holy spirit will
bring back to memory but it has to be in
there to come back to your memory amen
it doesn't say I'll suddenly download my
word into it has to come back to memory
so we need to be in God's word
so intercessory prayer okay
can I I'm sorry for interrupting you no
good before we leave that last one go
back just one you brought something up
when Christ was facing Satan
but he was doing it as a man yeah he did
not have the ability that he did when he
faced Satan in heaven and he threw him
out on his bum you know what I mean yeah
I'm sure Satan was more powerful than
him at that point you know well Jesus
said everything he did comes from the
father what's interesting is is that you
brought something out Christ spoke the
word
Satan knows what the Bible says yeah I
mean he's got the most brilliant
question Jesus yeah he's got the most
brilliant mind he's a million times
smarter than any human being
Jesus wasn't telling Satan something he
didn't know right so Jesus was not
speaking the word to Satan he was
speaking out loud what God's word says
and there's a verse and it may not be
here it may come up later on but in
Romans chapter 10 and I don't remember
if it's verse 10 or verse 9 somewhere in
there but he says something he says with
the heart a man believes unto
righteousness but with the mouth
confession is made unto salvation wow
when I was growing up I thought the word
confession meant to confess your sins
right if I confess my sins that'll get
me saved that's not what the word means
when you read it in the Greek like in a
strong concordance it means to profess
and speak out loud so true so Christ was
saying what had happened right before
Jesus was tempted
what event he was baptized he was
baptized what happened when he came up
out of the water at his baptism God
spoke and then the dove descended on
what did God say to Jesus this is my son
whom well pleased do you know what first
John chapter 3 verse 9 says
those that are born of God cannot sin
for God's word his seed remains in them
and they cannot sin for they are born of
God Jesus had just left the baptism
where God said out loud this is my
beloved Son Satan comes and says if
you're the Son of God make this Stone
bread Jesus said get thee behind me it
is written he was saying to himself it
is written I am the Son of God I know
who I am because I heard God's voice and
if we believe God sin has no dominion
over us amen
so we but we got to speak it that's
right you know I think speaking it is an
act of faith and we can say I can say I
got faith in that chair
but if if you say well go sit in and I'm
like nah then I don't have faith in it
right I have to of course I'm gonna sit
in So speaking is saying I believe it
because okay just like uh I remember
your wife's testimony and if you guys
haven't seen the dragon revealed you got
to watch it it's on our Channel
so you had come in and you told your
wife you wanted a divorce you guys are
going through this separation
but God was telling her that you guys
are going to be restored and she
believed it
and then God said tell your children
that you guys are going to be restored
and she's like no I can't do that
because
and then she realized I can't say it why
I'm doubting yeah why would I not tell
my children because there's some kind of
doubt what if it doesn't happen now
you've lied to your children so in faith
she told her children your father's
coming home amen that was an act of
faith that proved that she really
believed it do you know what's neat when
we speak out loud God's promises it's
showing him that we believe his word
amen do you remember
um and this is one of the best examples
that I've ever heard remember Abraham in
the Old Testament how old was he when he
had his baby that God had promised he
was you know 99 years old
what was Abraham's name before God
changed his name Abram Abram Abram
and I was like what's the difference
Abram it means a mighty Father
Abraham it means a father of a great
multitude what's the difference
the first one Abram means a father like
a governor over a house or over a tribe
you don't even have to have children
well it means like a figurehead
when God told Abraham your name is
Abraham now not Abram
from that day forward every time Abraham
met somebody and they asked him his name
he had to make a choice do I speak doubt
or do I speak Faith do I say Abram or
Abraham so you know Mikey reaches out to
shake hands with me and says what's your
name and I go man if I tell him my name
is Abraham he's going to say where is
your children I don't have any yet I
look like a fool wow but if I say my
name's Abram then I'm denying what God
Said from the day that God changed
Abraham's name from that day forward
every time he told him my name's Abraham
and if they asked where his children was
he says they're not here yet but they're
on the way amen hey we need to we need
to speak things as if they're already
here you know like if somebody if you're
going through a separation say
still call your wife that's my wife you
know speak it
so we're going to talk about
intercessory prayer I don't know if a
lot of people know about intercessory
prayer I found out years after I became
a Christian just what it was still
didn't know the real power of it I knew
that you know you could pray I heard a
testimony of somebody saying that they'd
be a Bible study group began to pray
that a certain person would come to
their study group and after they began
praying that person just for some reason
got curious about their study group and
came and it was a real
it was a real Supernatural type of
scenario like they somehow showed up or
whatever they knew it was an answer to
prayer but God's really been teaching me
a lot about intercessory prayers showing
me examples of it in the Bible such as
Ezekiel 22 29-31 says
the people of the land have used
oppression and exercise robbery and have
vexed the poor and needy yea they have
oppressed The Stranger wrongfully and I
sought for a man among them that should
make up the Hedge and stand in the gap
before me for the land that I should not
destroy it but I found none therefore
have I poured out mine indignation upon
them I have consumed them with the fire
of my wrath their own way have I
recompensed upon their heads saith the
Lord God what is being said here is
there was a wicked nation and God had to
bring righteous judgment upon them but
before he did he's like is there anybody
even praying for this city
and looked and found none found none
standing in the Gap found none that were
making up a hedge
you need to pray a hedge of protection
around your family you need to pray for
that lost family member a lost spouse or
lost son whatever it is pray for them
because it might literally be
it might buy them more time for God
that's what happened with uh was it
Abraham with Sodom and Gomorrah yeah so
another example right here Genesis 18 23
and 1916 says and Abraham Abraham Drew
near and said so the scenario is that
God was going to bring judgment upon
Sodom and Gomorrah but Abraham's nephew
right nephew nephew lot was in that City
and he didn't want a lot to be destroyed
so he's like pleading with the Lord and
he says and Abraham Drew near and said
wilt thou also destroy the righteous
with the wicked he said are you going to
destroy the righteous in there you're
going to destroy the whole city what if
there's righteous people in there and
the Lord being merciful
unto him and they brought him forth and
set him without the city so to fill you
in the Lord was saying no I won't
destroy the righteous or the wicked so
Abraham quickly realized lot is not even
righteous lot is worthy of death just
like everyone else
but because he was pleading with the
Lord the Lord sent two angels in that
City to rescue lot and his family and
pull them out amen the prayers of
Abraham literally saved the lives of his
nephew and family amen that's
intercessory prayer it's not just some
figurative thing like it's real it's in
the Bible and we have example after
example can I can I add something
actually go ahead go ahead do this one
first and then I'll you want to read it
no you go ahead okay so in Exodus 32
11-14 this is where you know the
Israelites were just freed from Egypt
they seen the waters part they walked on
dry land and Moses goes up to the
mountain to spend time with God and the
Israelites start worshiping a golden
calf so God's going to destroy them
rightfully so like he did everything for
them and they betrayed him they
committed spiritual adultery on God they
were committing fornication while
worshiping the God too exactly and Moses
besought the Lord his God and said Lord
why do thou why doth thy Roth Wax Hot
against thy people why are you angry
with the people which thou has brought
forth out of the land of Egypt with
great power and with a mighty hand
and the Lord repented of the evil which
he had thought to do unto his people it
was Moses pleading with the Lord like
give them another chance Lord like
please let me witness to them or
whatever and God changed his mind about
destroying them something that is
important I think for for all of our our
listeners to hear this
God didn't want to really destroy the
people I think he was testing he was
testing Moses because he wanted Moses he
knew Moses loved him and he wanted Moses
to experience what God felt amen so in
that situation Moses actually told the
Lord
Lord you brought them out with a mighty
hand out of Egypt you parted the Red Sea
I mean you you destroyed the greatest
army That Was Then known on the face of
the planet he said
if you destroy them now all these other
nations that heard what you did about
bringing them out of Egypt they're going
to say you weren't able to complete the
job that you started wow and then he
told the Lord he said and besides that
this is not your character yeah he said
so if you can't forgive them Moses told
the Lord to block my name out of your
book out of The Book of Life Moses was
like I would rather not be there if if
you are not going to have mercy on them
I think Paul says the same thing later
yeah in the New Testament and I felt the
same way before it believe it or not
like I remember reading that and being
like whoa that's that's a little too
much but I the closer I get to God the
more I begin to witness to people and
study the world looks at me and says wow
you've come a long way you're like
completely different but the closer I
get to God the more wretched I feel yeah
I realize that I am not holy the closer
I get to his Holiness the more I realize
like I'm not worthy and I've I've
sometimes just and that's the more it
makes me fall in love with him how can
he love me and I'm so messed up yeah
I've just been driving home before and
just
tears comes to my eyes because I'm like
you'd be just and destroying me yeah
Lord I'm not but he wants to save us
he's so long suffering with us
acts 7 59 and 60 says and they stoned
Stephen so this was the first Christian
martyr everybody all the Pharisees and
everything were just really hating what
Stephen was saying they were gnashing
their teeth on them and everything and
they stoned them and it says and they
stoned Stephen calling upon God and
saying Lord Jesus receive my spirit and
he kneeled down and cried with a loud
voice Lord lay not this sin to their
charge and when he said this he fell
asleep he died he as he's dying he's
pleading with the Lord don't let this
sin come against him can you imagine no
being stoned to death like a brutal
murder
and you're praying for those who are
murdering you Lord don't let this sin
come upon them I mean it's it's an
impossible thought but it's a it's a
straight reflection of what Jesus said
when he was on the cross in Luke 23
it says and when they were come to the
place which is called Calvary There They
Crucified him then said Jesus father
forgive them for they know not what they
do
this comes back to the the God of this
world has blinded them they didn't even
know what they were doing they literally
thought they were doing the work of God
by crucifying this false prophet God
actually
and you may bring this up later but it's
like what God wants is he wants somebody
to stand in the Gap yes it's like if I
stand in the gap for somebody first
thing I do is I confess my sins I make
sure God all of my sins known and
unknown I'm confessing those to you and
I'm confessing their sins even if I
don't know what they are I don't need to
know what they are but I'm confessing
that because they may not be yeah and
I'm claiming the shed blood of the Lord
Jesus Christ over them and over me and
by doing that
it's like it puts a buffer around
because Satan would kill every human
being in an instant in one moment he
would kill every human being on the face
of the planet he hates us because we're
going to take his place in heaven we're
going to be exalted to a position even
higher than the Angels had when they
fell
he hates Humanity
when we intercede and we claim the blood
of Jesus
God is then legally by his own rules to
the Warfare this great controversy God
is able to say the devil says you can't
touch that you can't go save that person
I'm going to kill them they're mine and
God says
yeah but I've got a son over here and a
daughter over here that are praying for
them I have every right to do this wow
yeah I'm thinking about like job when uh
Satan was gonna you know God was like
have you considered my servant job and
he's like well yeah you give them
everything take it away and and like for
us to pray I'm just picturing like I'm
imagining the spirit world and how Satan
wants to attack somebody who's doing
wrong but that loving spouse that loving
parent has been praying for them every
night Lord protect them don't let them
die without knowing you amen and and
Satan tries to go and there's a hedge of
angels around amen nope
Mikey's praying for them amen you can't
touch them
I mean that's deep the thing about like
we need to think about it realistically
this is real man let me if you don't
care let me read one more verse that
goes along with that Mikey this is in
Matthew chapter 18 verse 18 and 19. and
this is Jesus's words
he says verily I say unto you your name
whatsoever you shall bind on Earth shall
be bound in heaven and whatsoever you
shall loose on Earth shall be loosed in
heaven
again I say unto you
that if two of you shall agree on Earth
as touching anything that you shall ask
it shall be done for them of My Father
which is in heaven amen so it's like
when you have two or three people
instead of just one person praying that
makes even more difference yeah God says
if I if I had a whole church of people
or a whole Bible study of people a whole
group of friends you guys get together
and say hey every Wednesday eight
o'clock 8 P.M we're all going to pray no
matter where we are for this same thing
God hears that
and I don't understand the Dynamics of
why that makes such a big difference but
it does yeah I mean I I just think
there's power in numbers man it's like I
might not be able to push that truck
outside but if me and you get together
and push and then some 10 people yeah
so God can use anything you know a lot
oftentimes we're like how in the world
could God use this circumstance in my
life like what benefit does it is it for
me to be in this terrible situation God
can use it there's examples in the Bible
Joseph didn't want to be in the pit
but if he wouldn't have been in the pit
he wouldn't have got sold to the
Egyptian slave or the Egyptian uh people
who were buying a slave and become the
you know the leader of Egypt so
sometimes we have to go through certain
things and God allows them God doesn't
cause them that's that's the farthest
mind-blowing to me when I try to explain
to people I'm like look God didn't cause
this this and this to happen in my life
but because this and this and this has
happened in my life
he is able to somehow use it and twist
it and make it work out for good and it
it blows my mind I've seen it happen
over and over you know the Bible talks
about that in the Old Testament
especially second Chronicles chapter 20
God uses his enemies weapons against
them yeah so the devil's like I'm gonna
I'm gonna cause a car wreck and God goes
I wonder how many people I can save out
of this and not just save them but I
wonder if I could get them a brand new
car I wonder if I mean he can do
exceeding abundantly above everything we
can ask or imagine yeah so he does he
doesn't cause them but he can't allow
them because he sees the beginning from
the end and he's like I know that if I
allow this hardship
in this person's life they'll get closer
to me and there's there's a lot of
verses in the Bible that say that that
he uses our afflictions to draw us
closer to him and sometimes it's not
it's not only that God has allowed it
but sometimes we open the door to the
answer it's not like God goes oh yeah
I'm going to let the enemy go right in
there right if I open the door to the
enemy God can still say Eric you made
that mistake yeah but because this
person's praying I'm going to turn that
I'm going to I'm going to use this I'm
going to change the way things work so
it works out for your good amen Genesis
50 20 this is about Joseph here and it
says but as for you you meant evil
against me but God meant it for good
amen in order to bring it about uh as it
is this day to save many people alive
so yeah yeah how many hundreds of
thousands of Egyptians survived because
of Joseph and we can put apply the star
life
we might be in a bad situation to be a
great testimony that could save a
hundred people amen I'm willing it's
hard to say it but I've I've done it I'm
going through it now I'm willing to go
through something hard if I know the
outcome is going to be a hundred people
are going to receive Christ because of
it because of my testimony of going
through something hard and surviving it
you know amen also going through hard
things gives you a compassion for people
that you didn't have before
like if you have dealt with car trouble
and you see someone on the side of the
road you have sympathy like oh man I
know how bad that is if you've always
had a nice car you're probably like yeah
I'm just going to drive past them so
hard things can make you compassionate
for people that are going through that
same thing
Romans 8 28 says and we know we know
that all things not some things we know
that all things work together for good
to them that love God to them who are
called according to his purpose amen I
think that's awesome and then it goes
even deeper here in Isaiah 61 3 it says
to console those who mourn in Zion but
we can apply this to us all his promises
are for us
to give them Beauty for Ashes the oil of
joy for mourning the Garment of Praise
for the spirit of heaviness that they
may be called the Trees of Righteousness
the planting of the Lord that he may be
glorified
notice
all these things Beauty for Ashes
joy for mourning is going to glorify him
because we're going to say you know how
I got through it because of God there's
no way I could go through what I went
through without him amen
25 you want to read it no no go ahead
okay I'm enjoying listening Joel 2 25
and 26 says I will restore to you the
years that the swarming Locust has eaten
you shall eat in plenty and be satisfied
and praise the name of the Lord your God
who has dealt wondrously with you and my
people shall never be put to shame
can I can I add one to that please this
is one that my wife and I found after
the Lord had restored our love for each
other and our love for him and our
marriage
um and this is all through the Old
Testament uh specifically Isaiah 51
verse 3 it says for the Lord
shall Comfort Zion we are Zion we are
New Jerusalem spiritual Israel yeah
spiritual Israel he says the Lord shall
Comfort Zion he will Comfort all of her
waste places don't read her because
that's those people over there right
your yeah Eric he will Comfort all your
waste places and he will make your
Wilderness like Eden wow and your desert
like the garden of the Lord joy and
gladness shall be found therein
Thanksgiving and the voice of Melody God
says
I take a Wilderness and in the Bible the
Wilderness means a desolate place
and I take your desert and I'm going to
make them like Eden I'm going to make it
full of Trees of Righteousness and and
producing fruits of the spirit and and
joy and praise and that's what he he
loves to do that these are promises guys
God keeps his promises
Proverbs 21 1. I thought this was
interesting the king's heart is in the
hand of the Lord as the rivers of water
he turneth it with or so ever he will
amen God can turn a king's heart a lot
of kings are not righteous a lot of
kings of the world are prideful and
arrogant and
but God can melt that Stony heart he can
turn it into flesh you know that's
something that people will tell me
they'll say like if they're praying for
a child one of their children that's
strayed from the Lord I mean I've got
people that are like my son's been in
not my son but they all say that their
son has been in prison for you know 20
years you know and they've done all
these terrible crimes well you know they
made their bed they got a lie in it you
know and I say well pray for them
they're like Well everybody's got free
will and I'm like
so where's your faith yeah you know and
like you said God said he can turn the
heart of a king
it's funny because God won't override a
person's free will because that would be
wrong that's what the devil does yeah
but God says I'll win their will I I
can't I can't turn their heart against
their will but I'll win their heart
yeah if you had some some beautiful
woman that some young man is desperately
to you know meet and win her heart it
may take you a year it may take you five
years but if you're in love with her you
will win her heart God says there's
nothing too hard for me there's nothing
impossible for me so I can turn that and
he can change a person's heart so that
the person will love them without doing
it against their will by revealing
little tokens of love and by showing
mercies and it's God it's a miracle how
does he do that yeah he makes you fall
in love with him because he is love
Hebrews 12 2 says looking unto Jesus the
author and the finisher of our faith so
we get our faith from him and I'm
thinking about people you know who maybe
were raised in church and went astray
he begun that good work the next verse
Philippians 1 6 says being confident of
this very thing that he who has begun a
good work in you will complete it until
the day of Jesus Christ if you've seen
your spouse or you've seen your child
have a heart for God and they go astray
well he's begun the good work he will
complete it amen he's the author and
finisher of our faith we need to keep
praying we need to intercede for them
because there's power in that we've seen
it
Stephen Jesus Moses Abraham they
interceded and we've got to remember it
says he's the author and finisher he
Jesus is the word of God Amen the word
of God is the author and the finisher
that means I'm the one that said it I'm
the one that'll do it amen so we've got
to hold him to his word I love this one
Isaiah 42 16 because this shows the
um just how God is persistent says I
will bring the Blind by way they did not
know I will lead them in paths they have
not known I will make Darkness light
before them and crooked places straight
these things I will do for them and not
forsake them amen look there's one path
to God it's a straight and narrow
and if you go off that path
well he's going to bring you by a new
way he's got Plan B he's got plan C he's
going to keep doing everything he can
he's going to put that right song on the
radio he's gonna put that amen text
message the right friend to bump into at
Walmart that says hey how have you been
doing can I pray with you something will
show up in your mailbox a book that you
weren't expecting or yeah just pursuing
you at every angle amen
John 1 12 and 13 says but as many as
received him to them gave he power to
become the children of God even when
them that believe even to them that
believe on his name which were born not
of blood nor of the will of the flesh
nor of the will of man but the will of
God I think you got something to say
about this
about the like we all got free will
right yeah we do but it's like
it says there these people are born
again not by blood that means not human
effort nor by the will of the flesh that
means even your own flesh nor the will
of man but by the will of God wow so
that means God needs somebody to stand
in the gaps right it's funny because
Jacob when Jacob his name means a
deceiver a heel catcher that means he's
the guy that would trip the one in front
of him so he could win the race he would
catch his heel with his foot
when he was on his last you know Journey
with his his families and his brother
was coming to kill him
Jacob wrestled at night he was at night
sleeping praying with God and he was
like God I don't know what to do I mean
I've got two families I had to divide
them because I don't want both families
dead and he was like God I don't know
what to do and all of a sudden he felt a
man next to him grab a hold of him well
Jacob thought man this is a robber or
somebody's going to kill me so he starts
fighting with him well in the middle of
the fight this stranger reaches over and
touches the inside of his thigh and his
leg goes out of joint and Jacob realizes
this is the Son of God this is not a
regular man I mean for God for Jesus to
Condon sin to get down here on the
ground and wrestle with a human being I
mean he could just blink and it'd be all
over
but Jacob said something to him
Jesus told him he said let go of me for
the day breakth you know no man can see
God
and Jacob said
I won't let go of you until you bless me
wow you made a promise to my grandfather
Abraham
and he said I know you can't lie I know
your word is sure and Jacob said I will
not let go of you until you do for me
the blessing that you promised to me
amen through Abraham and because Jacob
refused to let go Jesus blessed him and
changed his name he said your name is no
longer he'll catcher sheet Jacob your
name now is Israel because as a prince
you have overcome with man and God as a
prince that means to be a prince you
have to be a son of the King Jesus was
calling him the Son of God as a Son of
God you have overcome
you would not let go deal in the New
Testament I don't remember where in the
gospels but there's a place where Jesus
said the Kingdom of Heaven suffereth
violence and to violent take it by force
and I used to battle with that verse
because I was like what does that mean
well then when I started reading and
looking up from different commentators
almost all of them pointed back to Jacob
wow the Kingdom of Heaven suffers
violence it means God will tolerate you
wrestling with him God will allow you to
keep beating on his door he's not
ignoring you he wants your faith to
pierce through the darkness and lay hold
on the word of God on Jesus amen and do
what Jacob did I won't let go of you
until you fulfill your word and there's
a parable of the the woman that was like
banging on the door and stuff we got a
bang on the doors of heaven and and just
keep pleading with God I will not let
you go until you bring my child to God I
will not let you go until you bring my
spouse back I will not let you go until
I get this house paid off whatever it is
and do you know what's funny and this is
totally on different subject but when I
was 13 or 14 years old I got really sick
my mom had to take me to the emergency
room while I was in there they found out
my blood sugar was 790. and they said
you got juvenile diabetes that's
lifelong there's no cure that's what
they said and I've done every kind of
herb and diet and I still do I believe
in that
but that didn't heal the blood sugar no
and
the Lord told me something he said Eric
he said read Isaiah 53 verse 3 through
6. it says God laid on Jesus the
iniquities of us all and by his stripes
we are healed well I started a number of
years ago I started reading all the
promises in the Bible out loud
everywhere I could find anybody that was
healed Old Testament and New Testament
and do you know that after just a couple
of months of doing that
I started having to decrease my insulin
and I got down to a point where I was
taking less than 10 units of insulin a
day before I was taking 120 530 units a
day that's amazing so it means God has
promised it don't give up just because
you don't see the answer immediately
keep thanking him he's already done it
thank him for doing it because his word
says so amen good things are worth
waiting for amen so faith we got to have
faith we got to believe all these things
that we're saying well you have to
believe them you can't just say you
can't just read it and kind of
you have to believe it and if you don't
believe it if you keep reading it out
loud and reading your name into it faith
will come by hearing and hearing by the
word of God Amen Romans 10 10. you read
this one for with the heart a man
believes unto righteousness that means
rightness
but with the mouth confession is made
unto salvation amen so I can believe
that God's healed me God's waiting for
me to praise him by speaking that God
has healed me amen so I get up in the
morning I say Lord your word says I am
fearfully and wonderfully made that my
soul knoweth the right way amen my wife
when her and I were you know divorced we
were divorced for five years almost I
mean just minus a couple of months five
years my wife would get up in the
morning with the children she'd say Lord
thank you for bringing my husband home
and people would say the judge signed
the papers he's not your husband she was
like my God didn't sign the papers he is
my husband amen so we've got to speak it
that's right I hear so many people going
through marital problems right now and
your story is uh as hope and so you're
speaking from the other side
you told me one time you said if my wife
would not have claimed those promises I
don't know if I'd be here right now
it might be easy for somebody to say
okay so so your wife was available five
years later maybe you just went back to
her but
but you really believe her prayers were
I know yeah yeah because I I wasn't I
hated God I was so mad at God about the
divorce I didn't want anything to do
with God I was angry at my wife didn't
want anything to do with her I had no
interest in anything that had to do with
god wow and if it was not for her
standing in the gap for me for almost
five years amen and claiming in the
first two maybe two and a half years it
was like she was she was trying to do it
all with flesh and blood yeah and that
just made things worse and finally God
really spoke to her and got her
attention and he said Sarah if you will
forget about your marriage start praying
for Eric's salvation that's right and
when she started doing that and she
started believing God's promises and
claiming his promises God did The
Impossible amen there's nothing
impossible even if your spouse is a
quote-unquote believer
if they want a divorce there's something
wrong because a marriage is a covenant
promise to God and if you're willing to
break a promise to God then there's a
problem yeah so salvation yeah do not
give up on your spouse do not just say
well the divorce is final
keep standing stand for your marriage
stand in the Gap I've seen tons of
stories of this happening amen Mark 11
24 says therefore I say to you whatever
things you ask when you pray believe
that you receive them and you will have
them amen When you pray it don't just
pray it don't just make some ritual out
of it believe it
Mark 10 27 says but Jesus looked at them
and said with men it is impossible but
not with God for With God all things are
possible all things even something that
with men it is impossible
With God all things are possible and
don't let don't let the word possible do
what it does in our English language
what's that what's how you say Well With
God all things are possible that leaves
it sort of like a vague Open Door yeah
he could do it if he wanted to right the
word doesn't mean that in the Greek when
it says With God all things are possible
it means god is full of divine power to
do it and make it happen that's right
Luke 1 37 says for with God nothing
shall will be impossible nothing no
thing
Mark 9 23 says Jesus said to him if you
can believe here's that word faith if
you can believe all things are possible
to him that believe your faith has made
you well she believed that if she
touched the Hem of His Garment she would
be healed because this is Jesus he's the
great physician and that was that was
promised in the Old Testament Malachi
really that there was healing in his
wings the word Wings means the borders
of the Garment wow there was two
different people that did that in the
gospels that's amazing so she believed
the word of God that's where she reached
amen you believe reach if you believe
praise thank speak it amen
and the the best part of this is Romans
2 4 says or do you despise The Riches of
his goodness forbearance and
long-suffering not knowing that the
goodness of God leads you to repentance
we were just talking about how he
doesn't Force anybody he's not going to
bend you and and fight your free will
but he will pursue you to the point
where you can't resist how could you
resist the long-suffering loving God and
it says goodness amen he's willing to
forgive you of the wretchedness all the
wicked things you've done all the sinful
acts all the fornication all the drugs
all those things he's willing to forgive
you who could resist that amen it's his
goodness that brings you to repentance
so I just want to encourage everybody I
hope that this
filled you with some kind of hope that
you didn't have before because
I don't hear a lot of churches preaching
this I don't hear this message preached
a lot that that we can believe and all
things are possible that we can
intercede for people and and
maybe we're the reason that they make it
to the kingdom literally our prayers for
them could be a life or death and I
believe that's a big responsibility for
us I believe that's our duty as
Christians if we truly love somebody and
we care about that person being in the
Kingdom get on your knees this is a
spiritual war we can't fight it any
other way we can't change the heart but
God says he can he can change the heart
of a king
because he's the king of kings
I was going to interject just one quick
thing Mikey there is a book that you
anybody can find online it's called the
ABCs of Bible Prayer by a pastor who
passed away years ago but his name was
Glenn yes but if anybody would like
something to really Inspire their faith
that would be the book to get and you
can you can probably find it as a PDF
for free yeah that is a great one and
even Roger Morneau we talk about him a
lot the power of prayer yeah these are
great resources and we'll put a link in
the description of where you can find
those but we're just so glad you guys
are with us here today if you were
blessed by this please click a thumbs up
it's a simple free and easy way to help
this ministry put a comment just say
Amen or or share a struggle that you're
going through share something that you
want prayer for we take those comments
seriously we get comments like that all
the time asking for prayer and if you're
new to this channel subscribe we're so
glad you're here with us today we will
see you next time on LED live God bless
you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you